[UNKNOWN] Also has effect on the latency that uses [UNKNOWN] as well as the loss
rate. Here we've shown how [UNKNOWN] latency
effect for two different users. The latency is
shown in terms of round trip time in milliseconds and the loss rate are shown
on the right side of the Y axis. Latencies are also shown on a log scale.
In this particular experiment, we start sending traffic here
and we stop sending traffic here, in both cases.
We can see that, even though power boost allows
you to just send at a higher traffic rate,
actually users may experience high latency and loss. Over
the duration that they're sending at a higher rate.
The reason for this is that the access link
may not be able to support the higher rate.
So if a sender can only send at r sustained for an extended period of time but
is allowed to burst at a rate r
for some shorter period of time, Then buffers may
fill up and the resulting buffers may introduce
additional delays in the network since packets are being
buffered up rather than dropped. TCP senders can continue
to send at higher rates, such as little r,
without seeing any packet loss even though the access link may not be able to
send at that higher rate. As a result,
packets buffer up and users see higher latency
over the course of the power boost
[UNKNOWN]. To solve this problem, you might imagine
instead that a sender might shape it's rate
never to exceed the sustained rate, Big R.
If it did this, then it could avoid seeing these latency effects.
So, search and senders, who are more interested in keeping latency under
control, then they are in-sending at births devoims, may wish
to run a traffic shaper in front of a power
boost enabled link. So shaping traffic to a rate of
less than this sustained rate r can prevent this buffering. More details
about power boost and the experiments that we've run to keep latency under
control in its presence are available in a paper we wrote called Broadband
Internet Performance, A view from the Gateway. Which appeared in Sigcomm 2011.